de quoi on meurt dans un injection de
graisse dans les fesses essentiellement
d'une embolie graisseuse c'est à dire
que si on injecte de la graisse dans un
gros vaisseau dans le muscle et bien la
graisse peut aller dans la circulation
générale boucher le poumon et on peut en
mourir d'ailleurs il faut savoir que
cette intervention est interdite en
Angleterre donc ça donne quand même le
niveau est d'accord et quand je vous
disais que tout à l'heure en France
c'est pas très pratiqué parce qu'on est
quand même très au courant des risques
et de l'intérêt relatif ça commence à
être docteur Cyril évoquait la
dangerosité j'ai lu un mort pour 3000
interventions ce qui a un taux
incroyable j'ai vu ça dans un revue
scientifique je sais pas si vous
confirmez ma question elle est simple
pourquoi est-ce qu'on interdit pas cette
opération si dangereuse c'est ce que je
dis effectivement c'est c'est une
intervention il faut toujours calculer
le bénéfice risque et moi je trouve que
cette intervention elle est extrêmement
risquée